Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,|||大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件现在正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造能为你带来源源不断收入的方式，而不是不断用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续性收入冲刺挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家的人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Getting started in a psychology career can be challenging at the best of times, but what
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Getting started in a psychology career can be challenging at the best of times, but what|||这些原则对你同样适用。还有由丽莎亲自送出的丰厚奖品可以赢取。如果你通过我的链接加入这个挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士一对一的教练辅导时间。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。快去我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent）查看，或者浏览我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个私信，我会把所有详情告诉你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在平时，开启心理学职业生涯就已经充满挑战，但是，
if you've got additional challenges that you are a non-UK citizen? How can this make getting ahead in your career in professional mental health in the UK even more challenging? What skills does it require? What barriers come up that you need to find a way through? And how are you also trying to learn, develop, shape yourself? And how at the same time of trying to navigate what it is to work in the UK, you are also learning, shaping, developing, and growing yourself professionally and personally. This is a brilliant episode, probably a long overdue one, and I hope you'll find it really interesting. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, and I'm a
if you've got additional challenges that you are a non-UK citizen? How can this make getting ahead in your career in professional mental health in the UK even more challenging? What skills does it require? What barriers come up that you need to find a way through? And how are you also trying to learn, develop, shape yourself? And how at the same time of trying to navigate what it is to work in the UK, you are also learning, shaping, developing, and growing yourself professionally and personally. This is a brilliant episode, probably a long overdue one, and I hope you'll find it really interesting. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, and I'm a|||如果你还面临额外的挑战，比如你不是英国公民呢？这会如何让在英国的专业心理健康领域发展事业变得更加具有挑战性？这需要哪些技能？你会遇到什么必须想方设法克服的障碍？同时，你又是如何努力去学习、发展和塑造自己的？而且，在努力适应英国工作环境的同时，你又如何在专业和个人层面上不断学习、塑造、发展和成长？这是一期精彩的节目，或许早就该推出了，我希望你会觉得它非常有趣。嗨，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名
qualified clinical psychologist. I am regularly contacted by people all over the world looking at how they can get started in a career in the UK and I have to say I often don't really know the answer but after today I will know the answers and you will too. So I hope you'll find this a fascinating listen even if you already have the right to work in the UK, there is so much beauty and brilliance to learn from our guest who is so thoughtful. And I really, really enjoyed our chat. I hope you will too. And I'll catch you on the other side. I am so delighted to welcome you along to the podcast Ananya. Thank you for joining us. Thank you so much for having me for this podcast. I've been listening to it for a long time now, and I'm just so delighted to be here.
qualified clinical psychologist. I am regularly contacted by people all over the world looking at how they can get started in a career in the UK and I have to say I often don't really know the answer but after today I will know the answers and you will too. So I hope you'll find this a fascinating listen even if you already have the right to work in the UK, there is so much beauty and brilliance to learn from our guest who is so thoughtful. And I really, really enjoyed our chat. I hope you will too. And I'll catch you on the other side. I am so delighted to welcome you along to the podcast Ananya. Thank you for joining us. Thank you so much for having me for this podcast. I've been listening to it for a long time now, and I'm just so delighted to be here.|||合格的临床心理学家。我经常收到来自世界各地的人们的联系，他们想了解如何在英国开启职业生涯，我必须承认，我通常并不真正知道答案，但今天之后我就会知道答案了，你们也会知道。所以我希望你会觉得这是一次迷人的聆听，即使你已经拥有在英国工作的权利，也能从我们这位思维缜密的嘉宾身上学到许多美好而闪光的东西。我真的非常非常享受我们的聊天。希望你也是。我们稍后见。阿纳尼亚（Ananya），我非常高兴你能来到播客。谢谢你加入我们。非常感谢邀请我参加这个播客。我已经听了很久了，能来到这里我真的太高兴了。
It's so kind of you to say, thank you. We connected on LinkedIn, as I do with many of my podcast guests. And if you have been a listener to the podcast, you will realize that I do mention LinkedIn a lot and when I suggested an episode you must have been like oh but you went with it and you were you were up for the challenge so thank you for that absolutely I mean I was thrilled when you'd sent a comment on my post and I was just telling all of my friends that oh my gosh I've gotten like someone asking me to be interviewed on a podcast. Do I am I am I eligible for this? Do I I mean, have I have I actually done enough to be on a podcast? So, yes, thank you so much for the opportunity. Oh, you're so welcome.
It's so kind of you to say, thank you. We connected on LinkedIn, as I do with many of my podcast guests. And if you have been a listener to the podcast, you will realize that I do mention LinkedIn a lot and when I suggested an episode you must have been like oh but you went with it and you were you were up for the challenge so thank you for that absolutely I mean I was thrilled when you'd sent a comment on my post and I was just telling all of my friends that oh my gosh I've gotten like someone asking me to be interviewed on a podcast. Do I am I am I eligible for this? Do I I mean, have I have I actually done enough to be on a podcast? So, yes, thank you so much for the opportunity. Oh, you're so welcome.|||你这么说太客气了，谢谢。我们在领英（LinkedIn）上结识，我和许多播客嘉宾都是这样认识的。如果你一直是这档播客的听众，你会发现我经常提到领英，当我建议做一期节目时，你当时一定在想“啊”，但你还是接受了，并且勇于迎接这个挑战，所以谢谢你。绝对的，我是说，当你在我的帖子下留言时，我兴奋极了，我一直在告诉所有的朋友：“天哪，有人邀请我去播客接受采访了。”我……我有资格参加这个吗？我有……我的意思是，我真的做了足够多的事情来上播客吗？所以，是的，非常感谢这个机会。哦，不用谢。
I think you have because actually your post stopped me in my tracks because you're an assistant psychologist. And I think that's a really fascinating conversation for us to have. But you aren't just doing assistant psychologist work within your paid assistant psychologist stuff, you are really looking at how you can maximise that for you, for your service, for your career. And actually, that was my experience of being an assistant that, you know, if you're able to carve out time to do relevant extra bits that that's beneficial for you but it is beneficial for the service too and I know from our pre-podcast chat there are really exciting additional reasons why I think this podcast chat is going to be really useful because you explained to me that actually you were born and raised in
I think you have because actually your post stopped me in my tracks because you're an assistant psychologist. And I think that's a really fascinating conversation for us to have. But you aren't just doing assistant psychologist work within your paid assistant psychologist stuff, you are really looking at how you can maximise that for you, for your service, for your career. And actually, that was my experience of being an assistant that, you're not able to carve out time to do relevant extra bits that that's beneficial for you but it is beneficial for the service too and I know from our pre-podcast chat there are really exciting additional reasons why I think this podcast chat is going to be really useful because you explained to me that actually you were born and raised in|||我觉得你有，因为实际上你的帖子让我驻足停留，因为你是一名助理心理学家。我认为这对我们来说是一个非常迷人的对话主题。但你在有薪的助理心理学家工作中，不仅在做助理心理学家的工作，你还真正在思考如何为自己、为你的服务、为你的职业生涯将这一点最大化。事实上，这也是我当助理时的经验，如果你能抽出时间做一些相关的额外工作，这对你是有益的，对你的服务也是有益的。而且从我们播客录制前的聊天中我了解到，还有一些非常令人兴奋的额外原因，让我觉得这次播客聊天会非常有用，因为你向我解释说，实际上你是在
India and then you are now you know doing your psychology career to become a UK qualified professional psychologist so I really think there's going to be so much for our audience to to learn here that's going to be really interesting so yeah let, let's dive in. Let's have a little bit of a think about, you know, let's start with your undergrad. So where did you do your undergrad? So I did my undergrad in Bangalore, India, from Christ University. And it was a triple major in journalism, psychology and English literature. And I decided to pursue psychology after that and I think I knew you know when I was doing during my university undergrad that I wanted to come to the UK I wanted to do a master's in the UK and I sort of applied pretty much
India and then you are now you know doing your psychology career to become a UK qualified professional psychologist so I really think there's going to be so much for our audience to to learn here that's going to be really interesting so yeah let, let's dive in. Let's have a little bit of a think about, you, know, let's start with your undergrad. So where did you do your undergrad? So I did my undergrad in Bangalore, India, from Christ University. And it was a triple major in journalism, psychology and English literature. And I decided to pursue psychology after that and I think I knew you know when I was doing during my university undergrad that I wanted to come to the UK I wanted to do a master's in the UK and I sort of applied pretty much|||印度出生长大的，然后现在你正在从事你的心理学职业，以成为一名英国合格的专业心理学家。所以我真的觉得这里有很多值得我们听众学习的东西，会非常有趣，所以，让我们深入探讨吧。让我们稍微思考一下，从你的本科开始。你在哪里读的本科？我在印度班加罗尔的基督大学（Christ University）读的本科。我的专业是新闻学、心理学和英国文学三主修。在那之后我决定继续深造心理学，我想我在大学本科期间就知道，我想来英国，我想在英国读硕士，而且我几乎申请了所有
everywhere that I could think of and I really liked the program at Newcastle University where they offered an MSc in clinical psychology so I enrolled and got through and I think my I think there's a there's sort of a sense of a pre-UK Ananya and a post-UK Ananya I feel like that was a huge huge change for me just from sort of being away from home being in a completely different country and just understanding you know how to how to deal with independence and how do you make the most of the time that you're away from home and also not feel homesick um so so that's sort of the the sort of academic journey that I've had so far thank you and I've got lots of friends in the northeast and I know I know them to be really friendly and really welcoming but
everywhere that I could think of and I really liked the program at Newcastle University where they offer an MSc in clinical psychology so I enrolled and got through and I think my I think there's a there's sort of a sense of a pre-UK Ananya and a post-UK Ananya I feel like that was a huge huge change for me just from sort of being away from home being in a completely different country and just understanding you know how to how to deal with independence and how do you make the most of the time that you're away from home and also not feel homesick um so so that's sort of the the sort of academic journey that I've had so far thank you and I've got lots of friends in the northeast and I know I know them to be really friendly and really welcoming but|||我能想到的所有地方，我非常喜欢纽卡斯尔大学（Newcastle University）的项目，他们提供临床心理学理学硕士（MSc）学位，所以我申请并被录取了。我觉得……我觉得有一种“来英国之前的阿纳尼亚”和“来英国之后的阿纳尼亚”的感觉，我觉得那对我来说是一个巨大无比的改变，仅仅是离开家、在一个完全不同的国家，并开始理解如何处理独立，如何充分利用你远离家乡的时间，同时又不会感到想家。嗯……所以这算是我到目前为止的学术旅程，谢谢。我在东北部有很多朋友，我知道他们非常友好、非常热情，但是
the accent is not always the easiest you know to to get to grips with and also absolutely the weather it's it's kind of it's kind of chilly up there um so it must have been for so many reasons such a big cultural shock for you it was i i struggled a bit during winter uh but i was very excited to see snow because that was the first time that I was actually seeing snow for the first time so that was very exciting but I have to say what I enjoyed the most about Newcastle was the affordability and how just how cheap everything was and in fact I really miss it now that I'm living in Oxford and everything is so expensive. Yeah and the Northumberland coast is really beautiful I've only been there once but I was was just blown away, you know, and yeah, just very, very different to life in the Midlands. Absolutely. to get even if you are you know a UK national there are so many more layers of complexity
the accent is not always the easiest you know to to get to grips with and also absolutely the weather it's it's kind of it's kind of chilly up there um so it must have been for so many reasons such a big cultural shock for you it was i i struggled a bit during winter uh but i was very excited to see snow because that was the first time that I was actually seeing snow for the first time so that was very exciting but I have to say what I enjoyed the most about Newcastle was the affordability and how just how cheap everything was and in fact I really miss it now that I'm living in Oxford and everything is so expensive. Yeah and the Northumberland coast is really beautiful I've only been there once but I was was just blown away, you know, and yeah, just very, very different to life in the Midlands. Absolutely. to get even if you are you know a UK national there are so many more layers of complexity|||那里的口音有时并不那么容易掌握，而且还有天气，那里的天气有点儿冷。所以出于很多原因，这对你来说一定是一个巨大的文化冲击。是的，我在冬天的时候有点艰难，但我很高兴看到雪，因为那是我第一次真正见到雪，所以非常令人兴奋。但我必须说，我最喜欢纽卡斯尔的地方是它的生活成本，每样东西都太便宜了。事实上，我现在住在牛津，什么都贵，我真的很怀念那里。是的，诺森伯兰海岸真的很美，我只去过一次，但我就被震撼到了，真的，和米德兰兹的生活非常非常不同。完全正确。即使你是一名英国国民，
involved for people that do not have you know there are so many more challenges involved for people that do not have indefinite leave to remain aren't there? Absolutely and I think that's one of the reasons why it's so difficult for international students to actually get an assistant psychologist post. And you're absolutely right. It's it's it's difficult even for home students to get on, let alone international students. And I remember when I was working as a support worker, it took me about six months to make all of my applications and interviews and I think I submitted about 57 applications and got about 15 interviews and I almost made the cut for four of them in fact the job that I've that I'm in right now was actually sort of the last one that I'd applied for. And I was very close to giving up on the dream of psychology
involved for people that do not have you know there are so many more challenges involved for people that do not have indefinite leave to remain aren't there? Absolutely and I think that's one of the reasons why it's so difficult for international students to actually get an assistant psychologist post. And you're absolutely right. It's it's it's difficult even for home students to get on, let alone international students. And I remember when I was working as a support worker, it took me about six months to make all of my applications and interviews and I think I submitted about 57 applications and got about 15 interviews and I almost made the cut for four of them in fact the job that I've that I'm in right now was actually sort of the last one that I'd applied for. And I was very close to giving up on the dream of psychology|||对于那些没有……对于那些没有无限期居留权（Indefinite Leave to Remain）的人来说，其中涉及的复杂层次要多得多，对吧？绝对是的。我认为这也是为什么国际学生想要获得助理心理学家职位如此困难的原因之一。你说得完全对，甚至对本土学生来说找这种工作都很难，更不用说国际学生了。我记得当我做支持工作者（support worker）的时候，我花了大约六个月的时间来完成所有的申请和面试，我想我大概投递了57份申请，获得了大约15次面试，其中有4次差一点就被录用了。事实上，我现在做的这份工作，其实是我申请的最后一份。我当时差点就要放弃在英国从事心理学梦想了，
in the UK, because it was just, yeah, I was just in a period where I thought, this is just not happening, everything sort of stacked against me. And it was it was quite a dramatic reveal for me at the end, because when my supervisor initially called me, she said, Well, you're sort of on a reserve list. There are two posts, one person has accepted the other person hasn't, and we'll let you know in a week's time. And I didn't really hear from her for a while. So I just assumed I hadn't gotten it and I got a call from her about a week and a half later and I was expecting bad news but she said yeah the job's yours and I just didn't know how I mean I just didn't know what to feel and and how to respond to it and just feel like I've actually done this that I've actually gotten an assistant psychologist post so it's quite surreal and I think ever since I've just felt like this role is what I've sort of
in the UK, because it was just, yeah, I was just in a period where I thought, this is just not happening, everything sort of stacked against me. And it was it was quite a dramatic reveal for me at the end, because when my supervisor initially called me, she said, Well, you're sort of on a reserve list. There are two posts, one person has accepted the other person hasn't, and we'll let you know in a week's time. And I didn't really hear from her for a while. So I just assumed I hadn't gotten it and I got a call from her about a week and a half later and I was expecting bad news but she said yeah the job's yours and I just didn't know how I mean I just didn't know what to feel and and how to respond to it and just feel like I've actually done this that I've actually gotten an assistant psychologist post so it's quite surreal and I think ever since I've just felt like this role is what I've sort of|||因为，是的，我当时正处于这样一段时期：我觉得这根本不可能实现，所有事情似乎都在与我作对。最后对我来说这是一个相当戏剧性的转折，因为我的主管最初打电话给我时，她说：“嗯，你大概在备选名单上。有两个岗位，一个人接受了，另一个人没有，我们会在一周后通知你。”我有一段时间没有接到她的电话，所以我以为我没被录用。大约一个半星期后，我接到了她的电话，我本以为会是坏消息，但她说：“是的，工作是你的了。”我当时真不知道该……我真不知道该有什么感觉，该如何回应，就觉得我居然真的做到了，我真的得到了一份助理心理学家的工作，所以感觉非常不真实。我想从那以后，我一直觉得这个角色就是我
trained for till now I'm finally using the knowledge and skills and and just my abilities to my to the full extent really. Yeah and well done to you because these jobs are not easy to get you know even when we're looking at doctoral psychology places there's often sometimes as many as 40 50 places on a course whereas for an assistant psychologist sometimes there's only one job and so you need to be the best person to get the job whereas there's a little bit more flexibility even getting doctoral places is tricky but there's a little bit more flexibility even getting doctoral places is tricky but there's a little more flexibility when there's only one job so you originally come over on a student visa can you work on a student visa could you guide us through that process
trained for till now I'm finally using the knowledge and skills and and just my abilities to my to the full extent really. Yeah and well done to you because these jobs are not easy to get you know even when we're looking at doctoral psychology places there's often sometimes as many as 40 50 places on a course whereas for an assistant psychologist sometimes there's only one job and so you need to be the best person to get the job whereas there's a little bit more flexibility even getting doctoral places is tricky but there's a little bit more flexibility even getting doctoral places is tricky but there's a little more flexibility when there's only one job so you originally come over on a student visa can you work on a student visa could you guide us through that process|||一直以来在为此接受训练的……我终于能把我的知识、技能以及我的能力真正发挥到极致了。是的，干得漂亮，因为这些工作并不容易得到，你知道的，即使我们看心理学博士学位名额，一个课程有时也往往有多达40、50个名额，而对于助理心理学家来说，有时只有一个工作岗位，所以你需要成为最优秀的人才能得到这份工作。虽然获得博士学位也很棘手，但相对而言有一点点灵活性，而当只有一个工作岗位时，灵活性就更小了。你最初是凭学生签证过来的，凭学生签证可以工作吗？你能为我们梳理一下这个过程吗？
so there is some um sort of leeway to work you can work for a certain number of hours that's stipulated within your visa so it's sort of part-time work that you can do whilst you're studying and after your sort of term ends and you finish your course then you can work full-time and it was after this student visa that I had applied for a post-study visa which lasted for two years and that was the visa that I was on when I was working as a support worker. Okay that's really good to know but I know that your current supervisor helped support your application to get a longer term working visa as well what type of visa is that called? So that's the skilled worker visa and that's the sort of very tricky one to get especially you know as an international student uh who's applying for an assistant
so there is some um sort of leeway to work you can work for a certain number of hours that's stipulated within your visa so it's sort of part-time work that you can do whilst you're studying and after your sort of term ends and you finish your course then you can work full-time and it was after this student visa that I had applied for a post-study visa which lasted for two years and that was the visa that I was on when I was working as a support worker. Okay that's really good to know but I know that your current supervisor helped support your application to get a longer term working visa as well what type of visa is that called? So that's the skilled worker visa and that's the sort of very tricky one to get especially you know as an international student uh who's applying for an assistant|||所以有一些……嗯，算是工作上的灵活性，你可以在签证规定的某个特定小时数内工作，所以在你学习期间你可以做一些兼职工作，而在你的学期结束、完成课程之后，你就可以全职工作了。正是在这个学生签证之后，我申请了毕业后工作签证（post-study visa），持续了两年，当我做支持工作者时，我拿的就是这种签证。好的，这真的很高兴知道。但我知道你目前的主管也帮你的申请提供支持，以获得长期工作签证，那是什么类型的签证？那是技术工人签证（skilled worker visa），这种签证相当难获得，特别是作为一个国际学生，在申请助理
psychologist post where it can be filled by any home student really um so my manager had to really sort of push for it and fight for it and uh i i don't think i can sort of express my gratitude enough for her to actually have seen so much value in my work and and sort of really want to keep me um in the service and continue working here yeah I think you've absolutely said it yourself you know they must have really seen just how unique special gifted talented and how for this profession you were and how what an asset you were going to be to to your current clients and your future clients and that actually to lose you from the UK mental health workforce would be detrimental you know so we want to keep you you know.
psychologist post where it can be filled by any home student really um so my manager had to really sort of push for it and fight for it and uh i i don't think i can sort of express my gratitude enough for her to actually have seen so much value in my work and and sort of really want to keep me um in the service and continue working here yeah I think you've absolutely said it yourself you know they must have really seen just how unique special gifted talented and how for this profession you were and how what an asset you were going to be to to your current clients and your future clients and that actually to lose you from the UK mental health workforce would be detrimental you know so we want to keep you you know.|||心理学家职位时——这个职位本来完全可以由任何本土学生填补，嗯，所以我的经理必须真正为此去推动、去争取。我觉得我怎么表达感激都不为过，感谢她真正看到了我工作的巨大价值，并且真的很想留我在这个服务部门继续工作。是的，我想你自己已经完全说出来了，他们一定真正看到了你是多么独特、特殊、有天赋、有才华，你是多么适合这个职业，你将成为你现有客户和未来客户的宝贵财富，而且实际上，如果在英国心理健康劳动力队伍中失去你将是一个损失，所以我们想留住你。
Yeah yeah I think I think I still remember the day when my supervisor sort of came to me to say that she had good news. And we both just broke down in the office. So does she get told before you do that your application has been successful? Yeah. So there's a process where we need to sort of through the leadership team, they need to secure funds for it so once that's secured the application pretty much goes through so she sort of came to me to say oh yes we've secured the funds and we both just broke down at that point. So that's funds for the role specifically so it's a fixed term contract or is that something unique and different with being a non-UK citizen? Sorry if that's a really weird question. No, no. So the funds are for the visa itself.
Yeah yeah I think I think I still remember the day when my supervisor sort of came to me to say that she had good news. And we both just broke down in the office. So does she get told before you do that your application has been successful? Yeah. So there's a process where we need to sort of through the leadership team, they need to secure funds for it so once that's secured the application pretty much goes through so she sort of came to me to say oh yes we've secured the funds and we both just broke down at that point. So that's funds for the role specifically so it's a fixed term contract or is that something unique and different with being a non-UK citizen? Sorry if that's a really weird question. No, no. So the funds are for the visa itself.|||是的，是的，我想……我还记得主管来找我的那天，她说她有好消息。然后我们俩就在办公室里哭了。那是比你更早被告知你的申请成功了吗？是的。有一个流程，我们需要通过领导团队为之争取资金，一旦资金落实，申请基本上就能通过了。所以她来找我说：“哦，是的，我们已经落实了资金。”在那一刻，我们两个人都崩溃了。所以那是专门针对这个岗位的资金吗？所以这是一个定期合同（fixed term contract），还是作为非英国公民独有且不同的一点？如果这是一个很奇怪的问题，请原谅。不，不。所以这些资金是专门用于签证本身的。
I'm on a permanent contract with in my current role. So the funds are for the duration of the visa itself. I see. OK, so it's basically, I guess, the UK government's assertion and guarantee that you're going to be employed for the duration of as long as it takes, basically. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. But it's good for you as well, you know. Does that mean then that you can essentially buy property? You can kind of put down roots in this country? Would that feel a bit premature at this stage? I think I think it's
I'm on a permanent contract with in my current role. So the funds are for the duration of the visa itself. I see. OK, so it's basically, I guess, the UK government's assertion and guarantee that you're going to be employed for the duration of as long as it takes, basically. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. But it's good for you as well, you know. Does that mean then that you can essentially buy property? You can kind of put down roots in this country? Would that feel a bit premature at this stage? I think I think it's|||我在当前职位上签的是永久合同。所以资金是针对签证有效期的。我明白了。好的，所以我想这基本上是英国政府的一种确认和保证，即你将在所需的整个期间内一直受雇，基本上是这样。完全正确。是的。是的。但这对外你来说也是一件好事，不是吗？那是不是意味着你基本上可以买房产了？你可以在这个国家扎根了？在现阶段这会不会觉得有点为时尚早？我想……我觉得
a bit early for that I still need to sort of get indefinite leave to remain before any of that can happen but it just gives me uh sort of a lot more stability around work and knowing that I won't have to I won't be kicked out of the country and have to go back home. Yeah, that's so good. So can you move to a different assistant psychologist role, for example? Or are you now kind of wedded to this one role? How does that work? So the sponsorship is through Oxford Health. So I could sort of change AP roles within the trust. But if I do have to move trust trust then I'd have to get the new trust to sponsor me as well which would be a whole other different thing. Okay so we're looking ultimately for four assistant psychologist roles in Oxford so if anyone knows of any do let Ananya
a bit early for that I still need to sort of get indefinite leave to remain before any of that can happen but it just gives me uh sort of a lot more stability around work and knowing that I won't have to I won't be kicked out of the country and have to go back home. Yeah, that's so good. So can you move to a different assistant psychologist role, for example? Or are you now kind of wedded to this one role? How does that work? So the sponsorship is through Oxford Health. So I could sort of change AP roles within the trust. But if I do have to move trust trust then I'd have to get the new trust to sponsor me as well which would be a whole other different thing. Okay so we're looking ultimately for four assistant psychologist roles in Oxford so if anyone knows of any do let Ananya|||现在谈这个还为时过早，在这一切发生之前，我仍然需要获得无限期居留权，但它确实给了我……在工作方面带来更多的稳定性，让我知道我不会被驱逐出境，不得不回国。太好了，真是太棒了。那么，例如，你可以转到另一个助理心理学家岗位吗？还是说你现在已经“绑定”在这个岗位上了？这是怎么运作的？担保是通过牛津健康（Oxford Health）提供的。所以我可以在信托基金（trust）内部更换助理心理学家（AP）的岗位。但如果我必须更换信托基金，那我就必须让新的信托基金也为我提供担保，这将会是完全不同的另一回事。好的，所以我们最终在牛津寻找四个助理心理学家岗位，如果有人知道任何空缺，请务必告诉阿纳尼亚
know not that you're looking to move on because I understand that actually what caught my eye was you were celebrating your year of having been an assistant psychologist and by the time this episode comes out it will probably be coming up for 18 months actually because it's taken us a little while to get this in the diary so yeah well done to you you know what I know from being a qualified psychologist myself but also from my work with aspiring psychologists and putting together the clinical psychologist collective and the aspiring psychologist collective book is that perseverance is key um and that you know what we know is that people who do have the capacity the tenacity and the grit to persevere are more likely to get there you know and that sounds really silly it absolutely does but if at any point we put our shovel and our work boots down
know not that you're looking to move on because I understand that actually what caught my eye was you were celebrating your year of having been an assistant psychologist and by the time this episode comes out it will probably be coming up for 18 months actually because it's taken us a little while to get this in the diary so yeah well done to you you know what I know from being a qualified psychologist myself but also from my work with aspiring psychologists and putting together the clinical psychologist collective and the aspiring psychologist collective book is that perseverance is key um and that you know what we know is that people who do have the capacity the tenacity and the grit to persevere are more likely to get there you know and that sounds really silly it absolutely does but if at any point we put our shovel and our work boots down|||——并不是说你现在正想要跳槽，因为我明白，实际上吸引我眼球的是你在庆祝自己成为助理心理学家满一周年，而等这期节目播出时，实际上可能已经快满18个月了，因为我们花了一点时间才把这个采访排上日程。所以，干得漂亮。你知道，根据我自己作为合格心理学家的经验，以及我与有志心理学家合作、编写《临床心理学家合集》（clinical psychologist collective）和《有志心理学家合集》（aspiring psychologist collective）这本书的经验，我深知坚持是关键。而且你知道，我们知道那些真正具备能力、韧性和毅力去坚持的人更有可能抵达终点。这听起来真的很傻，确实如此，但如果在任何时刻我们放下了铁锹和工作靴，
that then means we're not going to progress certainly we're not going to progress at that time and it's it's being able to keep going on a journey that feels like there might be no pot of gold at the end of the rainbow. There are no guarantees that can feel really tricky, can't it? And actually, sometimes people do burn out from that process. How did you keep the faith in Anya? Honestly, that's a bit of a tricky question. I think there's sort of a two-pronged answer, if I could say. I recently did an exercise that we actually do with our patients on myself, because it's actually a very lovely exercise to try out.
that then means we're not going to progress certainly we're not going to progress at that time and it's it's being able to keep going on a journey that feels like there might be no pot of gold at the end of the rainbow. There are no guarantees that can feel really tricky, can't it? And actually, sometimes people do burn out from that process. How did you keep the faith in Anya? Honestly, that's a bit of a tricky question. I think there's sort of a two-pronged response, if I could say. I recently did an exercise that we actually do with our patients on myself, because it's actually a very lovely exercise to try out.|||那就意味着我们不会取得进展，至少在那时我们不会取得进展。并且，能够在一段感觉彩虹尽头可能没有金罐子的旅程中继续前行，没有任何保证，这感觉真的会很棘手，不是吗？事实上，有时人们确实会在这个过程中精疲力竭。阿纳尼亚，你是如何保持信念的？老实说，这是一个有点棘手的问题。如果可以的话，我觉得这是一个双管齐下的回答。我最近对自己做了一个练习，这个练习我们实际上是和患者一起做的，因为这其实是一个非常棒的、值得尝试的练习。
It's called the Values Can't Sort intervention. And it basically sort of helps you go through certain values and helps you decide what your top three values are. It can be quite tricky to choose a top three. But the three that came out for me was around ambition, knowledge and hard work. And I think that sort of resonated so much with me to sort of reflect on the last five years and just everything that's happened. It's so centred around these three aspects of myself. And I think the other aspect of it
It's called the Values Can't Sort intervention. And it basically sort of helps you go through certain values and helps you decide what your top three values are. It can be quite tricky to choose a top three. But the three that came out for me was around ambition, knowledge and hard work. And I think that sort of resonated so much with me to sort of reflect on the last five years and just everything that's happened. It's so centred around these three aspects of myself. And I think the other aspect of it|||它被称为“价值观卡片分类干预”（Values Card Sort intervention）。它基本上可以帮助你梳理某些价值观，并帮助你决定你的前三个核心价值观是什么。要选出前三个可能会相当棘手。但对我和我契合的三个价值观是：雄心、知识和努力工作。我想这与我产生了很多共鸣，去反思过去五年以及发生的所有事情。它非常围绕着我自身的这三个方面。我想它的另一个方面是
is just how supportive my parents have been. And, you know, I come from a family that's extremely supportive around the kind of work that I do uh because mental health and psychology is not really considered um sort of very positively in in India just as of yet things are changing but changing quite slowly uh So I'm, I'm extremely grateful for my parents to have sort of kept that faith in me and the career that I've chosen. And yeah, I think it's, it's definitely a combination of those two things. Thank you. What a beautiful answer. Beautiful answer. Yeah, I traveled just before I got on
is just how supportive my parents have been. And, you, know, I come from a family that's extremely supportive around the kind of work that I do uh because mental health and psychology is not really considered um sort of very positively in in India just as of yet things are changing but changing quite slowly  So I'm, I'm extremely grateful for my parents to have sort of kept that faith in me and the career that I've chosen. And yeah, I think it's, it's definitely a combination of those two things. Thank you. What a beautiful answer. Beautiful answer. Yeah, I traveled just before I got on|||我父母是多么地支持我。而且，你知道，我来自一个对我的工作给予极大支持的家庭，嗯，因为在印度，心理健康和心理学目前尚未被非常积极地看待——虽然情况正在改变，但改变得相当缓慢。所以，我非常感谢我的父母对我和我所选择的职业保持着这种信念。是的，我认为这绝对是这两方面结合的结果。谢谢。多么美丽的回答。美丽的回答。是的，我在获得
the doctorate. So once I knew I had my doctorate place I traveled in India for five weeks and I I definitely did see that some of the people that would have been looked after or perhaps even in inpatient facilities in the UK were not it at points it felt a little bit like um some of the people who had acute needs, it almost felt like, it's going to sound really awful, but in days gone by in the UK, there were like court fools in kind of royal settings where felt would be service users in the UK almost had that aspect in society where people were standing around laughing at them and that was really hard to watch and so almost you seeing experiences like that in India and knowing that you didn't want that to be the case and you wanted to further a career in professional mental health care. Talk us through that. Yeah, I think just, you know, from what you've shared about your experience with India, I think you see a lot of that in sort of smaller cities, smaller areas. But things I think are changing
the doctorate. So once I knew I had my doctorate place I traveled in India for five weeks and I I definitely did see that some of the people that would have been looked after or perhaps even in inpatient facilities in the UK were not it at points it felt a little bit like um some of the people who had acute needs, it almost felt like, it's going to sound really awful, but in days gone by in the UK, there were like court fools in kind of royal settings where felt would be service users in the UK almost had that aspect in society where people were standing around laughing at them and that was really hard to watch and so almost you seeing experiences like that in India and knowing that you didn't want that to be the case and you wanted to further a career in professional mental health care. Talk us through that.|||博士学位之前去旅行了。所以一旦我知道我获得了博士学位名额，我在印度旅行了五个星期，我确实看到，在英国本会得到照顾、甚至可能在住院设施中的一些人，在某些时候，感觉有点像……嗯，一些有急性需求的人，几乎感觉——这听起来可能真的很糟糕——但在过去的英国，有些类似于皇室环境中的宫廷小丑，在英国会被视为服务使用者的人，在社会上几乎有这样一种面貌：人们站在周围嘲笑他们。这真的很难看。所以，当你在印度看到这样的经历，并知道你不希望情况是这样，你想要在专业心理健康护理领域进一步发展事业。跟我们聊聊这个吧。
quite rapidly in sort of the bigger metropolitan cities in India. People are accessing therapy, especially people from sort of, you know, Gen Z. And people are more sort of pro therapy at this point, which is really good. But I think the issue is that it's a very sort of there's only a small proportion of the population that recognises the importance of mental health and the need to access mental health care. And I know there are a few sort of mental health wards in India as well, but obviously they're not as sort of well defined as those that we see in the UK. And that's something that needs to be worked on. And there's probably no concept of a crisis team back in India, I think. So there's definitely a long, long way to go. But going back to your question around sort of how and why psychology
Yeah, I think just, you know, from what you've shared about your experience with India, I think you see a lot of that in sort of smaller cities, smaller areas. But things I think are changing quite rapidly in sort of the bigger metropolitan cities in India. People are accessing therapy, especially people from sort of, you know, Gen Z. And people are more sort of pro therapy at this point, which is really good. But I think the issue is that it's a very sort of there's only a small proportion of the population that recognises the importance of mental health and the need to access mental health care. And I know there are a few sort of mental health wards in India as well, but obviously they're not as sort of well defined as those that we see in the UK. And that's something that needs to be worked on. And there's probably no concept of a crisis team back in India, I think. So there's definitely a long, long way to go. But going back to your question around sort of how and why psychology|||是的，我想，从你分享的关于你在印度的经历来看，我认为你在一些较小的城市、较小的地区会看到很多这样的情况。但我觉得在印度一些较大的大都市，情况正在相当迅速地改变。人们正在接受治疗，尤其是……你知道的，Gen Z（Z世代）的人。而且目前人们更倾向于支持治疗，这真的很好。但我认为问题在于，只有极小一部分人口认识到了心理健康的重要性以及获得心理健康护理的需求。我知道印度也有一些心理健康病房，但很显然它们不像我们在英国看到的那么明确定义。这是需要改进的地方。而且我想在印度可能没有“危机干预小组”（crisis team）的概念。所以这绝对还有很长很长的路要走。但回到你的问题，关于心理学是
came up for me, I think this goes back to when I was in school in India, I was in sort of how and why psychology came up for me. I think this goes back to when I was in school in India, I was in sort of high school. And that was when I first had psychology as a subject. And I had the most amazing teacher, who just made me fall in love with the subject. And if I wouldn't have had her as a sort of a guide for me, I don't think I would have fallen in love with the subject. And it was something that came so naturally to me that I felt that, you know, I could ace examinations without really having to study much. And I spent a lot of time reading things outside my syllabus
came up for me, I think this goes back to when I was in school in India, I was in sort of how and why psychology came up for me. I think this goes back to when I was in school in India, I was in sort of high school. And that was when I first had psychology as a subject. And I had the most amazing teacher, who just made me fall in love with the subject. And if I wouldn't have had her as a sort of a guide for me, I don't think I would have fallen in love with the subject. And it was something that came so naturally to me that I felt that, you know, I could ace examinations without really having to study much. And I spent a lot of time reading things outside my syllabus|||如何以及为什么出现在我的生活中，我想这可以追溯到我在印度的学校里，我当时在……心理学是如何以及为什么出现在我的生活中，我想这可以追溯到我在印度的学校里，我当时在读高中。那是我就读高中的时候。正是在那时，我第一次接触到心理学这门学科。我遇到了一位最棒的老师，她让我深深爱上了这门学科。如果当初没有她作为我的引路人，我想我不会爱上这门学科。这对我来说是一件非常自然的事情，以至于我觉得，你知道的，我不需要花太多时间学习就能在考试中拿高分。我花了很多时间阅读大纲之外的书籍，
and sort of just wanting to know more and just get to understand things and I think that continued during my undergraduate degree as well where I used to do a lot of work outside of the the premed tater syllabus and I did sort of a research project, which subsequently got published. And I sort of had this idea in my head where I would say that, you know, by 18, by the time I'm 18 years old, I want to make sure that I'm a co-author. And by the time I'm 25, I want to be a first author, which I did achieve. I published my master's dissertation just in time. But yeah, the next step in the in the sort of aligned goals is to get onto the doctorate by the time I'm 30. So fingers crossed, hopefully that does happen.
and sort of just wanting to know more and just get to understand things and I think that continued during my undergraduate degree as well where I used to do a lot of work outside of the the premed tater syllabus and I did sort of a research project, which subsequently got published. And I sort of had this idea in my head where I would say that, you-know, by 18, by the time I'm 18 years old, I want to make sure that I'm a co-author. And by the time I'm 25, I want to be a first author, which I did achieve. I published my master's dissertation just in time. But yeah, the next step in the in the sort of aligned goals is to get onto the doctorate by the time I'm 30. So fingers crossed, hopefully that does happen.|||并且只是想了解更多、去理解事物。我想这种状态在我读本科期间也一直在继续，当时我经常做许多医预科（pre-med）大纲之外的工作，我做了一个研究项目，后来发表了。我脑子里有这样一个想法：我对自己说，在18岁之前——到我18岁时，我要确保自己是一个共同作者。到我25岁时，我想成为第一作者——我也确实做到了。我及时发表了我的硕士学位论文。但是，是的，接下来这一系列目标中的下一步是：在我30岁之前考上博士。所以祈祷好运，希望真的能实现。
Yeah, fingers crossed indeed. And so at the moment, that would be courses that offer self-funding um for the doctorate is that right yeah so i'm hoping by the time i'm 30 i should be able to uh apply for the nhs funded courses as well i see so you're hoping sometime in the next five years you get the indefinite leave to remain yeah absolutely okay amazing all right so tell us about some of the incredible opportunities obviously without sharing any client identifiable information but some of the incredible opportunities that that an assistant psychologist role affords to individuals i I think when you first start as an assistant psychologist, you're sort of at the absolute precipice of opportunities. You don't realise how much there is to do and how much there is to learn out there. It can be quite intimidating initially,
Yeah, fingers crossed indeed. And so at the moment, that would be courses that offer self-funding um for the doctorate is that right yeah so i'm hoping by the time i'm 30 i should be able to uh apply for the nhs funded courses as well i see so you're hoping sometime in the next five years you get the indefinite leave to remain yeah absolutely okay amazing all right so tell us about some of the incredible opportunities obviously without sharing any client identifiable information but some of the incredible opportunities that that an assistant psychologist role affords to individuals i I think when you first start as an assistant psychologist, you're sort of at the absolute precipice of opportunities. You don't realise how much there is to do and how much there is to learn out there. It can be quite intimidating initially,|||是的，确实祈祷好运。那么目前，那是提供自费的博士课程吗？对吧？是的，所以我希望到我30岁时，我也能够申请到NHS（国民保健制度）资助的课程。我明白了，所以你希望在未来五年内的某个时候获得无限期居留权？对吧？绝对是的。好的，太棒了。好了，那么跟我们讲讲一些不可思议的机会——显然在不分享任何客户可识别信息的前提下——助理心理学家岗位为个人带来的那些不可思议的机会。我认为当你刚开始做助理心理学家时，你几乎正处于机遇的悬崖边缘。你不会意识到外面有多少事要做，有多少东西要学。最初可能会相当吓人，
especially for someone like me who just likes to keep doing and doing a lot of work uh it can be uh can be quite overwhelming i i don't i my supervisor always says i i need to learn how to say no and stop putting too much on myself um but i think from the start i've sort of known that i wanted to get involved in research and I wanted to get involved in some more leadership roles as well. And I sort of had conversations with my supervisor around the core competencies of what it takes to become a clinical psychologist. And that's sort of the whole point of an assistant psychologist post where you sort of work on honing those skills so you've got clinical research leadership and within the clinical work I think starting up as an assistant psychologist in a crisis team has been absolutely phenomenal just being able to work alongside
especially for someone like me who just likes to keep doing and doing a lot of work uh it can be uh can be quite overwhelming i i don't my supervisor always says i i need to learn how to say no and stop putting too much on myself um but i think from the start i've sort of known that i wanted to get involved in research and I wanted to get involved in some more leadership roles as well. And I sort of had conversations with my supervisor around the core competencies of what it takes to become a clinical psychologist. And that's sort of the whole point of an assistant psychologist post where you sort of work on honing those skills so you've got clinical research leadership and within the clinical work I think starting up as an assistant psychologist in a crisis team has been absolutely phenomenal just being able to work alongside|||特别是对于像我这样喜欢不停地做、做很多工作的人来说，这可能会……可能会让人应接不暇。我……我的主管总是说我需要学会拒绝，不要给自己施加太多压力。嗯，但我想从一开始我就差不多知道我想参与研究，我也想参与更多领导力角色。我和我的主管围绕成为一名临床心理学家所需的的核心能力进行了对话。这正是助理心理学家岗位的全部意义所在——你在这个岗位上磨练这些技能，从而具备临床、研究和领导力。在临床工作中，我认为在危机干预小组中以助理心理学家的身份开始工作绝对是了不起的，能够与
service users who have such high risk to themselves, to others. And also, I feel like the more sort of crisis work I do, the more I realise that I thrive the most in high risk environments. I find it a lot more challenging, but also as rewarding as they are challenging um so with with respect to sort of clinical work i've i've seen how much i've changed just in the last year and how confident i've become in using the sort of interventions that we do with uh with service users and um we use a lot of uh cft and dbt uh interventions so compassion focused therapy, dialectical behaviour therapy skills. And also working in a crisis team, you realise that it's not a very long term support that's
service users who have such high risk to themselves, to others. And also, I feel like the more sort of crisis work I do, the more I realise that I thrive the most in high risk environments. I find it a lot more challenging, but also as rewarding as they are challenging um so with with respect to sort of clinical work i've i've seen how much i've changed just in the last year and how confident i've become in using the sort of interventions that we do with uh with service users and um we use a lot of uh cft and dbt uh interventions so compassion focused therapy, dialectical behaviour therapy skills. And also working in a crisis team, you realise that it's not a very long term support that's|||对自己、对他人具有如此高风险的服务使用者并肩工作。而且，我觉得我做的危机工作越多，我越意识到我在高风险环境中表现得最好。我发现这更具挑战性，但也和挑战一样富有回报。所以，关于临床工作，我看到了自己在过去一年里发生了多大的变化，以及我在对服务使用者使用我们所做的干预措施时变得多么自信。嗯，我们使用了很多基于……的CFT和DBT干预措施，即慈悲聚焦疗法（compassion focused therapy）、辩证行为疗法（dialectical behaviour therapy）技能。而且在危机干预小组工作，你会意识到这不是一种长期的支持。
out there. So having psychology embedded within a crisis team is important within itself. In fact, I'm one of the first assistant psychologists within the team. So I had to sort of start from scratch to work with patients we we do have sort of short-term interventions that we provide uh which is quite exciting um but on the other hand we've i've also been involved in a lot of research that um you know i'd like to sort of use to help the team understand team dynamics and working with certain patient populations. Ever since I worked as a support worker, I've been interested in understanding more about patients who've been diagnosed with the emotionally unstable personality disorder. I'm quite, I think I can use an entire hour just to talk about the disorder and why I'm so against it. I'm a huge feminist and I feel like this particular diagnosis is quite a stigmatised one,
out there. So having psychology embedded within a crisis team is important within itself. In fact, I'm one of the first assistant psychologists within the team. So I had to sort of start from scratch to work with patients we we do have sort of short-term interventions that we provide uh which is quite exciting um but on the other hand we've i've also been involved in a lot of research that um you know i'd like to sort of use to help the team understand team dynamics and working with certain patient populations. Ever since I worked as a support worker, I've been interested in understanding more about patients who've been diagnosed with the emotionally unstable personality disorder. I'm quite, I think I can use an entire hour just to talk about the disorder and why I'm so against it. I'm a huge feminist and I feel like this particular diagnosis is quite a stigmatised one,|||所以将心理学融入危机干预小组本身就很重要。事实上，我是团队中首批助理心理学家之一。所以我不得不从零开始与患者合作。我们确实提供一些短期干预措施，这相当令人兴奋。但另一方面，我也参与了大量研究，你知道的，我想利用这些研究来帮助团队理解团队动力学以及如何与特定患者群体合作。自从我做支持工作者以来，我一直对更多地了解被诊断患有情绪不稳定型人格障碍（emotionally unstable personality disorder）的患者感兴趣。我很……我想我可以花整整一个小时来谈论这个障碍，以及为什么我如此反对它。我是一个坚定的女权主义者，我觉得这个特定的诊断被严重污名化了，
which is used more often than not towards women. And in fact, I want to sort of work on this topic for my doctorate as well, which is why I feel this is sort of my stepping stone towards that dream maybe we'll talk about that for a separate episode maybe we'll get that booked in for autumn and beyond yeah well yeah definitely well done it sounds like you're doing incredible things but it also made me think about a service that I learned about recently which is actually only available in Wales currently. So if you're listening to this in Wales, you might already know about this, but it's called 111 Option 2.
which is used more often than not towards women. And in fact, I want to sort of work on this topic for my doctorate as well, which is why I feel this is sort of my stepping stone towards that dream maybe we'll talk about that for a separate episode maybe we'll get that booked in for autumn and beyond yeah well yeah definitely well done it sounds like you're doing incredible things but it also made me think about a service that I learned about recently which is actually only available in Wales currently. So if you're listening to this in Wales, you might already know about this, but it's called 111 Option 2.|||并且它往往更多地被用于女性身上。事实上，我也想在我的博士阶段研究这个主题，这就是为什么我觉得这是我通往那个梦想的垫脚石。也许我们可以为此单独做一期节目，也许我们可以把它预约到秋季或更晚的时候。是的，做得好，听起来你在做令人难以置信的事情。这也让我想起我最近了解到的一项服务，它目前实际上只在威尔士提供。所以如果你在威尔士收听这个节目，你可能已经知道了，它被称为“111按键2”（111 Option 2）。
And in Wales, that is a mental health, you know, crisis line, really, that we use in the same way for physical health stuff in England, should I say, and England and Scotland. But in Wales, there's one-on-one option too that you can, you know, you can do all sorts there. So you can phone up and say, I've run out of medication. What on earth do I do? Or you can say, actually, I'm really not coping very well. I need a referral to so-and-so team. Or, you know, I actually think I need the crisis team.
And in Wales, that is a mental health, you know, crisis line, really, that we use in the same way for physical health stuff in England, should I say, and England and Scotland. But in Wales, there's one-on-one option too that you can, you know, you can do all sorts there. So you can phone up and say, I've run out of medication. What on earth do I do? Or you can say, actually, I'm really not coping very well. I need a referral to so-and-so team. Or, you know, I actually think I need the crisis team.|||在威尔士，那是心理健康……你知道的，危机热线，我们在英格兰（应该这么说）以及英格兰和苏格兰以同样的方式将其用于身体健康方面。但在威尔士，有“111按键2”，你可以在那里做各种事情。所以你可以打电话说：“我的药用完了，我到底该怎么办？”或者你可以说：“事实上，我真的应付得很不好，我需要转诊到某某团队。”或者，“你知道，我真的觉得我需要危机干预小组。”
And they kind of help you do all of that so if anyone's listening to this and thinking oh i live in wales or near wales i'm looking for relevant roles they tend to be based within cmht teams um and there's a kind of a couple of people working for one one one option two so that might well be interesting for people but the work that crisis teams do is very specialist because what it is, it's like you said, it's acute cases of presentation, which I don't mind telling you that when I was an can you tell us what acute is and how that work might differ to a non-acute service? And it probably would have been really excellent for me to have properly looked into what the word acute meant. And I just sort of went, oh, no, really bad?
And they kind of help you do all of that so if anyone's listening to this and thinking oh i live in wales or near wales i'm looking for relevant roles they tend to be based within cmht teams um and there's a kind of a couple of people working for one one one option two so that might well be interesting for people but the work that crisis teams do is very specialist because what it is, it's like you said, it's acute cases of presentation, which I don't mind telling you that when I was an can you tell us what acute is and how that work might differ to a non-acute service? And it probably would have been really excellent for me to have properly looked into what the word acute meant. And I just sort of went, oh, no, really bad?|||他们会帮完成所有这些。所以如果有人听了这番话，心想“哦，我住在威尔士或威尔士附近，我在寻找相关岗位”，它们往往设在社区心理健康团队（CMHT）内部。嗯，有几个人在为“111按键2”工作，所以这对人们来说可能会很有趣。但危机干预小组所做的工作是非常专科的，因为它是——就像你说的——急性表现的病例。我不介意告诉你，当我是一名……你能告诉我们什么是“急性”（acute）以及这项工作与非急性服务有何不同吗？对我来说，如果当初能彻底研究一下“急性”这个词的意思，那可能就太棒了。我当时只是觉得：“哦，不，真的很糟糕？”
Oh, no. So yes, do always make sure that you properly understand the terms for the roles that you've been invited to, because acute means it's kinding kind of all elements of their life and we need to get involved we need to get involved now to to contain to diffuse to help people make changes that are hopefully going to make a difference how is that a better answer for if someone asked me what a cute is how would, how would you rate that answer? I agree. Oh, yeah, it's definitely a lot more than not good. But yeah, it's about sort of the intensity of work that we do as well that is needed for clients with acute presentations. And another aspect of crisis service that people often forget is that it's there to ensure that, you know, people can be supported in the
Oh, no. So yes, do always make sure that you properly understand the terms for the roles that you've been invited to, because acute means it's kinding kind of all elements of their life and we need to get involved we need to get involved now to to contain to diffuse to help people make changes that are hopefully going to make a difference how is that a better answer for if someone asked me what a cute is how would, how would you rate that answer? I agree. Oh, yeah, it's definitely a lot more than not good. But yeah, it's about sort of the intensity of work that we do as well that is needed for clients with acute presentations. And another aspect of crisis service that people often forget is that it's there to ensure that, you know, people can be supported in the|||哦，不。所以，是的，一定要确保你正确理解了你受邀面试的岗位术语，因为“急性”意味着它触及了他们生活的各个方面，我们需要介入，我们现在就需要介入来控制、来化解、来帮助人们做出有望带来改变的改变。如果有人问我什么是“急性”，这样一个回答怎么样？你如何评价这个回答？我同意。哦，是的，这绝对比“不好”要深刻得多。但，是的，这也是关于我们所做工作的强度，这是急性表现客户所需要的。危机服务的另一个人们经常忘记的方面是，它的存在是为了确保……你知道的，人们可以在
community rather than going to hospital. Yeah, excellent, excellent points between us. We've got a gold standard answer there, I think. So we are drawing to a close with our episode today. It's been an absolute pleasure speaking with you. And I think this is going to be an invaluable episode for anybody looking to get an assistant psychologist role, but especially for those who, you know, might have additional challenges linked to visa or non-residency. How has the episode been for you and of course if you can think of anything what advice might you have for any aspiring psychologists to avoid burnout on the way to where they're going yeah I think I think the episodes uh been quite emotional for me if I can say so it's it sort of made me realize how far I actually have come um and it's it's been a while since I, you know, sat down and thought
community rather than going to hospital. Yeah, excellent, excellent points between us. We've got a gold standard answer there, I think. So we are drawing to a close with our episode today. It's been an absolute pleasure speaking with you. And I think this is going to be an invaluable episode for anybody looking to get an assistant psychologist role, but especially for those who, you know, might have additional challenges linked to visa or non-residency. How has the episode been for you and of course if you can think of anything what advice might you have for any aspiring psychologists to avoid burnout on the way to where they're going yeah I think I think the episodes uh been quite emotional for me if I can say so it's it sort of made me realize how far I actually have come um and it's it's been a while since I, you know, sat down and thought|||社区中得到支持，而不是去医院。是的，非常棒，我们俩提出了非常棒的观点。我想我们在那里得到了一个黄金标准的回答。因此，我们今天的节目即将接近尾声。与你交谈绝对是一件乐事。我认为对于任何想要获得助理心理学家岗位的人来说，这将是一期无价的节目，特别是对于那些可能面临与签证或非居民身份相关的额外挑战的人。这期节目对你来说感觉如何？当然，如果你能想到什么，你对任何有志心理学家在通往目标的道路上如何避免职业倦怠有什么建议吗？是的，我想……我想这期节目对我来说相当情绪化，如果我可以这么说的话。它让我意识到自己其实已经走了这么远，嗯，而且我有一段时间没有……你知道的，坐下来思考
about, you know, and I know from 2020, and how much everything's changed since then. I think, I think the only sort of advice I give to avoid burnout is to, I don't know, try and prioritise yourself as much as it might feel selfish, I don't know, try and prioritize yourself as much as it might feel selfish, or, you know, difficult to do it, or just you might feel that, you know, it's, it's an indulgent thing. But this is something that my clinical leads and my supervisor keeps saying that, you know, you can't pour out of an empty cup. So really, the only way I've sort of kept myself to not burn out is by convincing myself that if I take a few days off, when I come back, I'm going to do a better job. So just have that little nugget there for you to convince you that you do need to take time off to take care of yourself and also just practice what you preach especially you know as as as mental health professionals
about, you know, and I know from 2020, and how much everything's changed since then. I think, I think the only sort of advice I give to avoid burnout is to, I don't know, try and prioritise yourself as much as it might feel selfish, I don't know, try and prioritize yourself as much as it might feel selfish, or, you know, difficult to do it, or just you might feel that, you know, it's, it's an indulgent thing. But this is something that my clinical leads and my supervisor keeps saying that, you know, you can't pour out of an empty cup. So really, the only way I've sort of kept myself to not burn out is by convincing myself that if I take a few days off, when I come back, I'm going to do a better job. So just have that little nugget there for you to convince you that you do need to take time off to take care of yourself and also just practice what you preach especially you know as as as mental health professionals|||关于，你知道的，我知道从2020年开始，自那以后一切都发生了多大的变化。我想，我给出的避免职业倦怠的唯一建议是，我不知道，试着把你自己放在首位——尽管这可能感觉很自私，我不知道，试着把你自己放在首位——尽管这可能感觉很自私，或者，你知道的，很难做到，或者你可能会觉得，你知道的，这是一种纵容。但这是我的临床负责人和我的主管一直在说的一句话：空杯子是倒不出水的。所以，我保持不精疲力竭的唯一方法就是说服自己：如果我休假几天，当我回来时，我会把工作做得更好。所以，这就当是一个小贴士送给你，说服你确实需要花时间休假来照顾自己，同时也要言行一致，特别是——你知道的——作为精神健康专业人员，
working with patients who've who are going through very difficult times you're out there telling them you need to be kind to yourself but sometimes as professionals we need to be kind to ourselves as well we absolutely do and everybody should reach for some kind of education on compassion focused therapy, I think. And if you like, I don't want to just listen to my podcast. It is filled with compassion. I did a post on LinkedIn yesterday about our younger selves, actually, and what they might be proud of. So it's really nice to kind of have that resonated throughout today's episode as well but my post was actually the first time I was ever on tv I was 17 and it was in an audience for watching a tv show being recorded with a lady called Trisha Goddard and actually in the last six months I've been on the Trisha
working with patients who've who are going through very difficult times you're out there telling them you need to be kind to yourself but sometimes as professionals we need to be kind to ourselves as well we absolutely do and everybody should reach for some kind of education on compassion focused therapy, I think. And if you like, I don't want to just listen to my podcast. It is filled with compassion. I did a post on LinkedIn yesterday about our younger selves, actually, and what they might be proud of. So it's really nice to kind of have that resonated throughout today's episode as well but my post was actually the first time I was ever on tv I was 17 and it was in an audience for watching a tv show being recorded with a lady called Trisha Goddard and actually in the last six months I've been on the Trisha|||与经历非常艰难时期的患者一起工作，你在外面告诉他们你需要善待自己，但有时作为专业人士，我们也需要善待自己。我们绝对需要，而且我认为每个人都应该去接触某种关于慈悲聚焦疗法的教育。如果你愿意的话，我不仅希望你听我的播客。它充满了慈悲。事实上，我昨天在领英上发了一条关于我们年轻时的自己的帖子，以及他们可能会为之自豪的事情。所以，这种共鸣贯穿今天的节目真的很好。但我的帖子实际上是我第一次上电视，当时我17岁，我是在现场观众席观看录制一个由一位叫特里沙·戈达德（Trisha Goddard）的女士主持的电视节目。事实上，在过去六个月里，我上了
Goddard show as a guest three times and 17 year old Marianne you know she'd have been absolutely thrilled with that so yeah it's really important to think about where we've come from as well as where we're going to and don't forget to be really you know give ourselves some pats on the back for for that hard work and that progress it's really important message well done Ananya. Definitely. Thank you so much for your time today I will be watching your career with eager interest and if you would like to do an episode on quite contentious diagnosis these days of EUPD then let's get that in the diary. Thank you for your time. Thank you so much for having me here, Dr. Marianne. And absolutely, yes, we'll definitely get in touch with you for another episode. I think it's going to be an interesting one.
Goddard show as a guest three times and 17 year old Marianne you know she'd have been absolutely thrilled with that so yeah it's really important to think about where we've come from as well as where we're going to and don't forget to be really you know give ourselves some pats on the back for for that hard work and that progress it's really important message well done Ananya. Definitely. Thank you so much for your time today I will be watching your career with eager interest and if you would like to do an episode on quite contentious diagnosis these days of EUPD then let's get that in the diary. Thank you for your time. Thank you so much for having me here, Dr. Marianne. And absolutely, yes, we'll definitely get in touch with you for another episode. I think it's going to be an interesting one.|||特里沙·戈达德的节目三次作为嘉宾，17岁的玛丽安——你知道的——她会对那感到欣喜若狂。所以，是的，思考我们来自哪里以及我们要去哪里真的很重要，并且不要忘记——真的——为我们的辛勤工作和进步给予自己一些鼓励和拍拍肩膀，这是一个非常重要的信息。干得好，阿纳尼亚。绝对的。非常感谢你今天抽出时间，我会满怀热切地关注你的职业生涯。如果你想做一期关于当今颇具争议的诊断——情绪不稳定型人格障碍（EUPD）的节目，那就让我们把这个排上日程吧。谢谢你的时间。非常感谢玛丽安博士邀请我来这里。当然，是的，我们一定会联系你录制另一期节目。我认为那会非常有趣。
Perfect. Thank you so much for your time and hope you have a lovely summer. Thank you. Oh, what an absolute privilege it was to speak with Ananya. I really, really valued our chat and I hope you did too. You know, she's absolutely reflecting in action. She's reflecting on action. She's doing all of those good things. She's just growing by the minute. You can almost see it. I would love to know what you think. What do you think of this episode? Has this ignited thoughts, feelings, questions for you? Do come and let me know in the Aspiring Psychologist Community free Facebook group, which is also the exclusive home of Marianne's
Perfect. Thank you so much for your time and hope you have a lovely summer. Thank you. Oh, what an absolute privilege it was to speak with Ananya. I really, really valued our chat and I hope you did too. You know, she's absolutely reflecting in action. She's reflecting on action. She's doing all of those good things. She's just growing by the minute. You can almost see it. I would love to know what you think. What do you think of this episode? Has this ignited thoughts, feelings, questions for you? Do come and let me know in the Aspiring Psychologist Community free Facebook group, which is also the exclusive home of Marianne's|||太完美了。非常感谢你的时间，祝你有一个美好的夏天。谢谢。哦，能与阿纳尼亚交谈真是莫大的荣幸。我真的非常非常珍视我们的聊天，希望你也一样。你知道，她完全在行动中反思，在行动后反思。她正在做所有这些美好的事情。她几乎每分钟都在成长。你几乎都能看得出来。我很想知道你的想法。你觉得这期节目怎么样？这是否激发了你的想法、感受和疑问？快来“有志心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist Community）免费脸书群组告诉我吧，这也是玛丽安专属的
Mindset and Motivation sessions, which happen on Friday morning, please do come along and join the group. If you like this episode, then I think you'll like what Ananya said was one of her favorite episodes. And that was with the lovely Phil Pamperlove, who is an end stage trainee clinical psychologist. I recently saw that he just submitted his thesis. So well done to you, Phil. And the episode that she particularly liked was the reflective growth across a psychology career. So if you haven't yet listened or watched that one, please do because I think you'll really like that too. I did mention the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book and the Clinical Psychologist Collective book in today's episode if you haven't checked
周五早上的思维与动力分享会，请务必来参加并加入我们。如果你喜欢这一集，我想你也会喜欢Ananya所说她最喜欢的一集。那是和可爱的Phil Pamperlove的对话，他是一名临近毕业的临床心理学实习生。我最近看到他刚提交了论文，所以祝贺你，Phil。她特别喜欢的那一集是关于心理学职业生涯中的反思性成长。所以如果你还没听过或看过那一集，请去看看，因为我想你也会非常喜欢。我在今天的节目中提到了《有抱负的心理学家合集》和《临床心理学家合集》这两本书，如果你还没看过
those out please do the reviews are beautiful um if you've read those books and haven't left me a review please do because it helps us to demonstrate that they are worth reading please if you haven't left us a review on apple podcasts and a rating five stars would be lovely on spotify or apple podcast please do because it just takes a moment and it is the kindest thing you can do absolutely for free to help me know that you like the content that I create welcome some further nurturance and guidance the aspiring psychologist membership is available to you I'm currently in the stages of doing a website redesign. So who knows, by the time this episode comes out, it might be on its shiny new home. You won't be able to miss it on socials. I'll be talking about
它们，请去看看吧，书评非常棒。嗯，如果你读过这些书但还没给我留下书评，请写一个，因为这有助于我们证明它们值得阅读。如果你还没有在Apple Podcasts上给我们留下评分和五星好评，请在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上这样做，因为这只需要一会儿时间，而且是你完全免费能做的最友善的事情，能让我知道你喜欢我创作的内容。如果你想获得更多滋养和指导，“有抱负的心理学家”会员资格随时为你开放。我目前正在进行网站重新设计。所以谁知道呢，等这集节目播出时，它可能已经搬到了闪亮的新家。你在社交媒体上绝对不会错过它，我会到处谈论
that everywhere. So do come and follow me on socials where I am Dr. Marianne Trent, everywhere you could hope to imagine. Thank you so much for being part of my world. Be kind to yourselves. Let me know if you've got any future topic ideas for episodes i'll see you very soon the next episode will be along on youtube from 10 a.m on saturdays and wherever you get your podcasts from 6 a.m on mondays then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different
那个。所以快来社交媒体关注我吧，无论你在哪里能想到，我都是Dr. Marianne Trent。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。对自己好一点。如果你对未来的节目有任何主题想法，请告诉我，我们很快就会再见。下一集将于周六上午10点起在YouTube上播出，周一上午6点起在你获取播客的地方上线。让这成为你的指南，有这个播客陪在你身边，你将迈向取得资格的道路。这就是由Marianne博士主持的《有抱负的心理学家》。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书，觉得里面关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。这让我惊叹于有这么多不同的
routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通往成功的途径，而且并没有哪一种是唯一完美的方式，这让我充满信心，觉得我并不是在用错误的方式做事，从而减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就放不下这本书了。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。